Tenemos la ecuación 3/4 de "x" más 2 es
igual a 3/8 de "x" menos 4.
Podríamos resolver esta ecuación como lo
hacemos usualmente, agrupando los términos
en "x" quizás del lado izquierdo y las constantes
del lado derecho, pero las sumas y restas
de fracciones en ocasiones se complican, así es que lo que voy a hacer desde el principio
en este video, es multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación por un número para eliminar las fracciones.
Y la mejor manera de hacerlo es,
¿cuál es el número más pequeño?
Que si yo multiplico ambos lados de la ecuación
por él, se eliminan las fracciones, se hacen
números enteros, pues bien, ese número más
pequeño es 8, el número más pequeño es 8,
voy a multiplicar ambos lados de esta ecuación por 8.
Me puedes preguntar,
¿oye Sal y cómo obtuviste el 8?
Obtuve el 8 porque encontré el mínimo común
múltiplo de 4 y 8, el número más pequeño
que es divisible entre 4 y 8 es 8, así es que cuando multipliquemos por 8 vamos a deshacernos
de las fracciones, veámoslo.
8 por 3/4, es 8 por 3 entre 4,
lo voy a hacer aquí a un lado, entonces
tenemos 8 por 3 entre 4, esto es igual...
esto es 8 entre 4, es 2, nos queda 2 por 3
es igual a 6.
Así es que 8 por 3/4 de "x" es igual a "6x"
más 8 por 2...
más 8 por 2 es 16, acuérdate que cuando
multiplicamos todo un lado de la ecuación
por un número, tienes que distribuir ese
número, así es que 8 por 2 es 16 y el lado
izquierdo es "6x" más 16, esto es igual a
8 por 3/8 de "x", estos 8 se cancelan y nos queda
simplemente "3x" menos 8 por 4 = 32, "3x" menos 32.
Y ya tenemos una ecuación más cómoda, ahora
agrupemos términos en "x" del lado izquierdo
y las constantes del lado derecho, eliminemos
"3x" del lado derecho, para esto restemos
"3x" del lado derecho y también lo tenemos
que hacer del lado izquierdo,
restamos "3x" a ambos lados, es la mejor manera de eliminar ese "3x" que tenemos del lado derecho
¿y qué nos resulta?
del lado izquierdo es "6x" menos "3x" es igual
a "3x", 6 menos 3 es 3 más 16
y esto va a ser igual a "3x" menos "3x" es igual a 0, por eso hicimos todo esto, de tal manera que
solo nos queda la constante que es -32.
Bien, ahora eliminemos este 16 del lado izquierdo,
para eso restemos 16 del lado izquierdo
y también lo restamos del lado derecho,
¿qué nos resulta?
Del lado izquierdo nos queda "3x" que se mantiene,
16 menos 16 es 0 por eso hicimos esto
y del lado derecho nos va a quedar, -32 menos 16
esto es igual a -48, ahora vamos a despejar
la "x" para esto dividimos entre 3, dividimos
entre 3 del lado izquierdo
y dividimos entre 3 del lado derecho.
Del lado izquierdo nos queda 3 entre 3 es
igual a 1, esto es igual a "x"
y del lado derecho nos queda -48 entre 3,
esto es igual a -16.
Y ya hemos terminado, "x" igual a -16 es la
solución de nuestra ecuación.
Veamos que este valor de "x" realmente funciona
para la ecuación original, la ecuación original
no tenía esos 8 a ambos lados.
Sustituyamos entonces en la ecuación original,
tenemos entonces que 3/4 que multiplica a
"x" que es 16 más 2, tiene que ser igual
a 3/8 que multiplica a -16 menos 4...
menos 4.
¿Qué nos da esto?
3/4 por -16, tenemos aquí -16 entre 4 que
sería -4, esto sería entonces 3 por -4,
3 por -4 es igual a -12...
-12 más 2...
-12 más 2 tenemos del lado izquierdo,
que es igual a -10,
¿y del lado derecho qué tenemos?
Del lado derecho tenemos 3/8 por -16, -16
entre 8 es igual a -2,
así que esto de aquí es 3 por -2 que es igual
a -6 menos 4... -6 menos 4 es igual a -10.
Así es que cuando "x" es igual a -16 se cumple la ecuación original pues ambos lados son iguales a -10.
Y así hemos concluido.